you guys ready for this one yes
sexual harassment investigation launched
into three middle schoolers wrong use of
pronouns
they were charged under title ix
according to the school these three kids
because they refused to say they them
one kid actually stood up to she says
quote she had been screaming at one of
brandon's friends to use proper pronouns
calling him a profanity and his friend
is very soft-spoken and kind of just
sunk down into his chair braden finally
came up defending him saying he doesn't
have to use proper pronouns it's his
constitutional right to not use you
can't make him say things
so apparently these kids were in trouble
the mom found out
this is in wisconsin they're saying that
because the kids refuse to use the
pronouns they're getting they're getting
heavily penalized we also know the fbi
is investigating parents who are
opposing this stuff
um
it was uh uh who was it i'm forgetting
who who tweeted this
maybe i'm forgetting the guy's first
name um mcintyre oh rn rn yeah sorry
forget your name dude he tweeted that
that the soft power they use to bring
the stuff into schools
will become hard power
and i'm like
it is hard power they are going to the
kids they're screaming at them swearing
at them and if the kid's like i'm not
going to say it then they get charged so
i don't know what that means when they
said they were charging them
apparently the news says an
investigation
let me read they filed a complaint
against them
an investigation was launched a title
nine complaint was filed against them so
what what is that what does that mean
she says i received a call from the
principal letting me know that i was
going to be receiving an email with
sexual harassment allegations against my
son
she says uh the investigating said he's
allegedly charged with sexual harassment
for not using proper pronouns so here's
this is what i'm saying look if anybody
says
this word is offensive and you have to
use this word i'll say that word's
offensive to me so how about i use this
word which is neither and we'll call
them blows bloof you're a blowf also
keep in mind these are the people these
are the people who are saying that
groomer is a needlessly harsh term to
describe adults insisting upon having
secret sexual conversations with
children then they turn around and say
not using someone's pronoun is sexual
harassment
dude this
these kids are national heroes that
stood up to this i don't know what the
situation is around what they if there
was a fight beforehand if part of this
is because there was violence involved i
really don't know the whole story but
you cannot bully people into using your
language in this country
well apparently you can you can try but
it's going to get national attention
you're going to look like the bad guy
for doing it
i hope so guys everybody have spaghetti
gate no they have language police in
france
so
i'm in france
they i'm pretty sure they do but i'm in
canada yeah yeah yeah i meant to say
french-speaking canada there you go
correction is that quebecois so in uh
i think it was in montreal
you have to have it all the stores
french is the big word and then english
is small so they're like language police
make sure and there's an italian
restaurant selling spaghetti and they
got fined because they were like you
didn't put the french word and they were
like spaghetti
so like
that they're the bad guys like when
you're trying to tell people you can't
you have to speak a certain way you have
to use certain words
you typically are it is frowned upon
right yeah big time i don't know if it's
like just me or if it seems like
they're coming so hard after kids like
even with the video game stuff it's like
leave the kids alone why do you care
it's like
at this point i'm like
don't make me tap the sign like people
are like right yeah
don't make me tap the sign um
it's like everything there just just
leave the kids alone leave the kids
alone remember that song that that told
the parents to leave hey teachers leave
those kids alone yeah it's a good song
do you remember that one song where they
said we'll convert your children yeah
yeah it was a san francisco choir yup
gay men's choir i think it was and this
is this is the
golden rule of the left right or one of
the many rules
they will scoff at the idea that they're
doing something call you paranoid for
thinking that they're doing something
and then a few years later they go ha i
was doing it the whole time as if
they're cheeky or edgy and it's like no
we knew that that's what it was we know
what you're up to we have how many years
ago is it five years now when jordan
peterson yeah we came out about that
that bill
c-16 c-16 look what's happening here in
the united states
i mean this is people people keep
believing it's not going to get worse
and i'm saying to people
this is this is what i said you know a
couple weeks ago would you rather
have a job
and your kid is with groomers for eight
hours a day or be homeless with your kid
i mean i i'm not telling you which one
is the right choice i don't have kids
i'm saying like this is basically what's
happening there are people like i can't
speak up i can't do anything about it
i'll lose my job
my kids got to go to school and
otherwise i have no one to watch them
it's like okay i hear you i mean the
groomers have your kids and they're
doing this to them but you know i think
they should come up with a system of
like neighborhood uh homeschooling moms
where like you'd have somebody let's say
within the neighborhood there is one or
two moms that
chose to not work or to stay home and
then the kids around that neighborhood
go to that uh mom's house and spend the
day and learn like the mom's already
homeschooling her kids so one or two
other students is not gonna make a
difference but at the same time it's
gonna make it easier for people to just
have their kids home schooled instead of
sending them to school like
i
don't have kids but i feel like if i do
i'm always so busy and so i
procrastinate a lot and you know all the
video game and dragon ball but to be
honest with you i i think i i have to
make time to
home school because i i just don't see
myself sending my kids to these places
like come back
oh you know mommy um i found out i'm gay
i'm like
shut up joshua you're three oh my gosh i
love this also you don't want to play
video games because they they haven't
commented on roe v wade so yeah
here's the important thing in this story
when the mother was asked some say this
could show rebido
and her son are against the lgbtq plus
community she said not at all not at all
my children have been raised to love
everybody equally you know what i'd say
i'd say i don't know about any of that
but if this is what they're doing i
guess apparently but not a single you
had that um matt walsh
was it was it the matt walsh thing on um
on dr phil
yes
yeah they but but they had had this um
instance where this woman was like we're
not we're not against the lgbt community
you know we're not at all just our kids
it's like dude
if that's what they're hiding behind and
that's encompassed in it then i guess
if they're if they're grooming your kids
if they're screaming at your kids if
they're using law to go after your kids
and then someone says do you oppose the
community i'd say doing this yes yeah
well joe joe rogan came out about it i
have a headline from the daily wire that
says rogan blasts people upset about
quote groomer term here's what's more
important not having people groom your
effing kids under the guise of i'm an
lgbtq educator looking good did you guys
see the viral gentler was trending
earlier yeah and i did a segment talking
about it because i'm just like i feel
like it's bait what what joe rogan said
was there are groomers in schools
you know they're creepy weirdos they
they beat it in front of kids it happens
all the time
you got kids being groomed how many of
them are hiding behind lgbtq
so then genter goes not a single person
has ever
you know beat off in front of kids and
then said they were lgbtq so that no one
got mad and i'm like i don't recall joe
actually saying those things so gent did
this performative outrage where he said
something that never happened or joe
never claimed so that he could come out
and go after him and this is the problem
having that's happening is
people like genkuger don't google search
these things he didn't even look up
because there's like if you google
search teacher exposes and all that
stuff it's insane how many stories there
are about teachers
just doing these things to kids it's
nuts
and then i'm like why would you say this
do you want the world to be better do
you want people to stop abusing kids
let's take the lgbtq thing and just put
it aside for a minute people abuse kids
joe rogan said people abuse kids why why
act like that's not happening
seriously
so everybody started posting pictures of
horses i guess yeah so
this is this is part of the problem like
let's say we could just completely
separate these two issues out from one
another the groomer teachers from the
lgbtq issues
even if we could do that what the left
has made abundantly clear
is that if somebody is a sexual abuser
all they need to do is claim some kind
of lgbtq status and the left will do
everything they can to make sure that
story is ignored
not talked about
yo that reminds me of that transgender
woman who went to women's president you
guys say that
and then she got she
whatever this person uh flipped yeah um
got two women at the prison flips yeah
pregnancy yeah
yeah right right right
i mean look i i i think the issue is
there is a a cult
that wants to
push their religion on people they're
authoritarian about it
i i don't care what your faith or
ideology is so long as you are
libertarian about it now you can talk
about the things you like but when it
comes to the stuff with kids adult
activities with children then it's just
like no no we don't we don't do that
here and they're advocating for it and
then worse like i'm sure i had
somebody throughout my whole life a
teacher that was gay like i i don't care
they didn't tell me about it i feel like
the only thing that i actually liked
about when teachers told the story about
their lives was the fact that i was able
to you know not pay attention there's
nothing going on there's no class i just
do my own thing text my friends but it's
like to me it's it's not relevant for my
education when you tell me about your
wife your kids or your partner or
whatever i just think that as a time of
like okay now i get to goof off with my
friends and blah blah blah like it's
it's not necessary for a child to be
educated for them to know
that you went hiking with your uh gay
partner like
we're gonna we're gonna have some a
couple lefties on the show next week
it's gonna be really really really good
yeah because i think what happens is
you know we'll be like hey look here's a
really bad story this book genderqueer
has overtly adult activities described
in images maybe that shouldn't be for
kids and then all of these left-wing
podcasters come out and they're like
you're banning books you're banning
books and i'm like okay when they're
banning books based on the ideas i can
understand that but they're like trying
to remove sexual imagery
why are you defending why are you
defending these books why is the
washington post the new york times and
all these left persons i will i will
love to talk to them about it we should
get a copy of those books too so we can
show them in person in person don't make
me tap this because we can't because we
can't show it on youtube yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you